each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
miraculous um we're welcome to have peng
peng you hear from Johns Hopkins from
sunny Baltimore to sunny Seattle and
pangs gonna Oh snowy Baltimore 22 not
snowy Seattle beautiful Seattle and
things going to talk about language
modeling trying to predict the next word
that that was a stupid joke anyhow go
ahead pack it and it's my pleasure to
present my thesis work here and welcome
and you can stop me anytime you want and
if you don't see anything clear so
basically I'm dealing with language
model which assigns probability
distribution over word sequences and we
always break up the probability
distribution to conditional probability
distributions so we estimate
probabilities of words given the history
words that happen in the past and this
can be seen as a regression problem and
traditionally language models are used
for many pattern recognition problems
including speech recognition in the
machine translation and language model
serves as a prior knowledge of the
language and sorry so a very simple but
powerful solution to the language model
problem is called Ingram language models
and in which you look at the N minus 1
items in the history instead of the
entire history and and use maximum
likelihood estimate to compute the
probabilities from training data we're
in this equation here sees basically the
count of anger and happening in any
training data and this is a course the
best for training data but we have
tremendous data is Parsons
and because any training data and the
real test data you're going to see are
different and most of the Ingram's you
can observe in the channel data will not
be in the test date and to give you an
idea we if we take the upenn treebank
portion of Wall Street Journal which has
about 1 million words for training data
and eighty two thousand words for test
data and the vocabulary we we use ten
thousand word open vocabulary and words
are words that are not in the vocabulary
are mapped to a special unknown token so
if you look at anger and statistics in
fact more than fifty four percent of the
trigrams are not in the training data
and it goes up to eighty-six percent for
the sixth gram and this very sparse list
problem actually makes language modeling
a very difficult regression problem and
the Ingraham model as we present here
needs at least the vaca Versailles
raised to the nth power that number of
words to in order to cover all the
Ingram's yes not unique Ingram is by
token up by type
so of course they're there there are
more data and there's no data like more
data in fact burger and meals in 98 they
already tried something called
just-in-time language model where they
look at search engine to query the
Ingraham they are going to see and a get
account for that engram from the web and
there's more work in that direction for
example Joe and rose and fell into of
2001 they used altavista to estimate
Ingram counts from the web and there's a
interesting work by bank-owned brio they
found actually for many natural language
processing problems efforts should be
directed toward data selection
collection instead of new learning
algorithms and after that there are
works trying to get a ingram counts or
data in text format from the web and one
of these these approaches the bullock 0
at aw approach the collective web text
by carrying the web using frequent
Ingram's from their small training data
and the collected data from University
of Washington was used in last year's
rich transcription speech recognition
evaluation and so actually we argue that
the web data is not the solution to the
data sparseness problem simply because
the web argue arguably has everything
but at the same time is also also noisy
and in fact by the study of jew and
Rosenfeld the web does not have
everything for example what I'm talking
right now you some of the words you
probably or the Ingram's you probably
cannot get from the web and in fact the
retry it 24 random web new sentences and
there are about 453 trigrams out of
which
46 were not covered by out visa that was
in 2001 so and sometimes for problems in
a specific domain that domain in domain
training data is not always easy to get
and that's also one of the problems so
so far I have presented the problem and
so there have been a lot of research in
dealing with the sparseness and i'm
going to give you an overview on that
and then i'm going to talk about my
approach the random forests approach for
language modeling and with some
experiments so basically people tried
all kinds of smoothing techniques what
smoothing does is to take out some
probability mass from the Ingram's in
the training data and distribute among
the others that you cannot see in a
chain data and they're having a
tremendous amount of work in this area
and over 10 different smoothing
techniques were proposed and among which
according to the study by chain and
goodman in 98 the interpolated
connection I smoothing is consistently
the best language models molding
technique the interpolated connection I
smoothing is of this form here in this
equation where C is again the count from
of an n-gram event from the Cheney data
and there's a discount constant D there
to take the probability mass from the
scene Ingram's and redistribute
according to a lower order connection I
distribution to other engrams so other
than that their work in work clustering
where people try to combine words into
equivalence classes so that the
vocabulary size will be much smaller and
Goodman showed in 2001
all components of a word clustering
model need to use smoothing a proper
smoothing and he also showed the
enterprise it interpolated cannot and I
again worked the best for this classroom
model and also there's decision tree and
instead of classroom words a clusters
histories into equivalence classes and
this seems to be a very appealing idea
but only negative results were reported
according to a study by putignano San
generic so also their models that are
smooth by the definition maximum entropy
models and neural networks and one thing
for the max management model is that
there's almost no difference in
performance from the interpolated
connection I and it's later on it showed
that it's actually quite close even in
the solution form to interpolating last
night by good man so the neural network
model represents words in real vectors
and use your network to compute the
posterior probabilities and the models
actually work pretty well if
interpolated with internal interpolated
canesten I again so he relies on the
kinetics moving again and they're also
work beyond engrams I would say this is
also dealing with sparseness problem
because it uses longer histories and
represent the longer histories by
parsing techniques using syntactic or
semantic information and there's work by
caliber genetic and by gorg cherniak and
those are parsing techniques and also
the there's almost parsing technique
where people use semantic information
the all those models actually achieved
significant improvements over the Ngram
models and we we know that actually all
the models here are the component have
the same sparseness problem as the anger
and because each component of those
parsing models are modeled by ingram
model and smoothing is also very
important for those approaches therefore
our motivation is actually a better
smoothing technique is often very
desirable and if we can use the
available data in a better way it will
help our applications and also the
improvements in smoothing should also
help other means of dealing with data
sparseness problem and i will show
actually it works for clustering and
also for the structure language model of
calvin genetic so our approach is an
extension to decision tree language
models in which we try to overcome some
problems of decision tree language
models for example the local optima and
data fragmentation in decision tree
construction and the basic idea is to
use random forests instead of a single
decision tree a random forest is a
collection of randomly constructed
decision trees and before going into the
random forest I'm going to present how
we are going to construct the decision
trees and a decision tree is is a an
equivalence classification of histories
and each leaf in a decision tree is
specified by a set of questions and
whose answers will lead from the root
note to leaf node and therefore each
leaf corresponds to a subset of
histories and also
a subset of the training data you are
going to see and therefore in this way
all the histories in the training data
are partitioned or classified so in a
data-driven approach decision trees are
constructed from some training data and
the construction requires three basic
things one is the set of possible
questions by in a decision tree we ask
question that each node and we ought to
know what questions to ask and there
there there has to be a criterion
valuating the desirability of the
questions and since we have a large
amount of possible questions we won't
know which one is the best for a current
node and also we need a construction
stopping rule in the tree growing
procedure or we can grow the tree until
it's a completely grown and then prone
it back using some also some post
pruning rule and here's a the example in
trigram right we have three words in
turn trigram and the questions we look
at our about the positions for example
is the word w minus I which means the
words in eighth position in the history
in some set s and/or in in the
compliment through SC and so there are
two possible positions for trigram only
and each pair the set s and its
complement defined he finds a possible
split of a decision tree node and also
of the training data and here we want to
emphasize that the set s and is
compliment they are complements with
respect to training data so anything
that any word that did not occur in a
chain data will not be included in the
set s or s complement and we
deal with that separately calcification
all just word identity just word
identity so we can see actually in the
decision she or node gets less data than
its ancestors because the Trinity de is
split into two directions and we can
obtain the essence compliment by some
exchanger algorithm which is a greedy
algorithm and graphically this is a for
example we have some training data in
this ABA and stuff and the words in both
are the words we're going to predict so
in this case we have on a and B and so
yeah at the beginning we have this node
which has all the histories before we
construct the decision tree and this is
a perfect case we're just look at the
first word in the history we know we can
just distinguish the words to be
predicted perfectly like if we have the
first word a then we know in the
training data the predicted word can
only be a and and vice versa so if we
have a new event DVD in the test data
and we're lucky and it goes to the right
direction and predicts the future word
be perfectly but often we have cases
like you know we know how to go where to
go from of this energy but the future
word never occurred in that arena in the
histories in that note and in this case
a DB and B has count 0 in the lab node
and another way in another case we have
a new event CBA and now since we have
only a and B
as the first word in the training data
we don't really know where to go from
this node from the root node here so
those are the two cases we're going to
deal with in our decision trees in order
to deal with this we actually grow a
decision tree until the maximum depth
using only the training data here by
maximum depth I mean either each leaf
node has only one history in it so
there's no way you can split further or
all the histories there have the same
statistics and it doesn't make sense to
split them further so the questions are
automatically obtained as the tree is
constructed and we use only training
data likelihood to evaluate the
questions and therefore we have a very
efficient algorithm that can construct
the trees very quickly and we don't
perform any smoothing during the tree
growing and after that we are going to
prone the decision trees to maximize
somehow doubt data likelihood yes
histories and the leaf nodes must have
the same statistics do you mean the
relative frequency distribution over the
future word right every history is the
same right
it's very often that some histories they
have only one word in the predicted
position in the training data and the
some histories will share the same word
in that case it doesn't make sense to
split that note so we during the pruning
of the decision tree since we use held
out data we need to incorporate some
kind of smoothing technique because many
of the engrams from the how the data
will not be seen in a in a training so
actually we extend other cannot nice
moving in this case to handle the
smoothie here's the again the connection
is moving on top on the top the first
equation of there and I highly
highlighted the differences between the
connection is moving and our decision
trees moving the main main difference is
in the count before in the connection I
account of a some Ingram is basically
from the channel data you you count how
many times it happened for the decision
tree is slightly different because we
have now equivalents classifications of
histories so the count of a word given a
node in the decision tree noted by the
equivalent class fee here is the account
of that word following any of the
histories in a in the decision tree node
basically you add all the counts
together to get the count for that node
and other than that it's almost
identical and of course the
interpolation weight has to be adjusted
because of that as well and we should
note that here if we use the connection
I a lower order probability distribution
for smoothing all histories in the same
note are not smooth in the same way
because they
you may not share the same lower order
history if you have two words in the
history and you drop one the one you
keep from this tree to a history to
history may not be the same and also we
only use leaves as equivalence classes
after the trees approved in that case if
we look at the equivalence
classification remember we have the case
where we stuck in some intermediate node
for some Ingram we don't know where
which direction to go in that case the
equivalence classification mapping will
be empty function so all the count of
all the words in the vocabulary will
have zero account with that now I will
say is a now note with that now note and
therefore the first term in the second
equation will always be zero and so the
interpolation weight will be simply 14
for that particular node and we use only
the lower order connection I
distributions for that case right yeah
so is it is supposed to be recursive
formula it is recursive in if you look
at the formula but I did not mention the
detail about connection is moving
because the lower order count for
connection I distribution is different
from the the normal count that we use
it's not like you count from the Shannon
data how many times the by Graham
occurred and they use that as your
account you actually count how many
times that diagram occurred in a
different trigrams so it's basically a
different definition of counts
that's why I use the head there too so I
offer this there are still problems with
a decision tree construction that we did
not address basically the training data
fragmentation problem as the tree is
constructed we have less and less data
the questions are selected on the only
basis of less and less data and they may
not be reliable anymore in the nodes
close to the leaf and also the exchange
algorithm we use to obtain the pair's
SNS compliments it's a greedy algorithm
and also the tree growing algorithm also
with the pruning is also greedy and in
some cases we can have deep trees there
are parameters for pruning the trees if
we set the parameters in some way we
have deep trees then we feed the Trinity
a very well and it will not generalize
to to any tested instead if we have
shallow trees then the histories are not
sufficiently refined and we again lose
the predictive power of of all the
histories in that note so in order to
deal with this we borrowed the idea from
leo breiman in random forests and he
applied the idea of random forest too
many relatively small problems of
classification and regression he uses
different random samples of data and
also randomly chosen subsets of
questions to construct a certain number
of decision trees and then applies a
test data to all the different decision
trees to get the class labels for that
data there's k here for example k
different class labels
and finally the winner gets also accept
priority decisions for the final
decision in order to use this in our
problem before that I give you just a
simple example if you have three trees
and two of them Cara classified test
data as alpha then the final decision
will be alpha and the three trees are
randomly constructed in order to use
this in our problem remember we asked
questions about positions only so it's
possible to randomize the selection of
positions to ask about in which case we
have only three alternatives we have for
a trigram we have two positions either
we ask about position one or position
two are the better of the two and we can
also actually it's very important to
randomly initialize the greedy exchange
algorithm since the algorithm results in
lots of different solutions for
different initialization and it's always
a local optima and it's better to
explore different local optima in
different trees if we construct a
hundred decision trees for example then
we as before in the decision tree model
we have a decision tree a language model
probability for the i3 here and the
final estimate will be simply the
average of all cheese and we take only
the average and hoping that by the law
of large number this converges to the
expectation of the probability as may in
where the random variable here is the
tree itself and of course the space of
the trees is enormous and we cannot get
all the trees to to really compute the
expectation
and that's why we use the average and
our random decision tree construction
will be like sampling in the tree space
yeah what if notice of the form is
position I is the wording position I in
this particular set of words and I know
my questions you ask yes okay that's the
only form yeah good so I didn't get the
random construction of the trees yes in
addition to selecting the position
you're asking all so you could also
randomly select which subset to ask
questions about is that what you what
you mean by random initialization it's
close actually the we have for each
particular position we have a collection
of words from the training data right
and we initially randomly split them
into two disjoint sets and now the
exchange algorithm will move things
around and see if there's any
improvement so that initialization can
be randomized so each time you run you
will get a different solution but it's
not like you sampling is happening a
kind of good yes yes so you only
basically started off initially with a
random random partition you could
imagine asking a question randomly at
each step right that's actually the
effect of the randomly initialize
initialization is actually the random
selection of the possible questions and
only the good questions and we actually
asked questions only we use only local
all tomorrow as the possible questions
directly it will certainly have it back
through our yeah yeah exactly so you
don't do like bagging type stuff for you
where you randomly selecting I I don't
present the results here but I did that
too and it seems begging works well with
this randomization just begging is not
but did you also make them getting
sidetracked do you also try the exchange
algorithm accepting bad splits with some
small probability like that veneering
type idea no I didn't yeah just friends
so any
we'll reach of even the tree in a
candida yes but a test date that is no
guarantee it's not guaranteed
um
that's when in this equation here it
will be mapped into a now node and go
back up to the connection I know order
okay so now i'm going to present some
results in using this random forest
language models and for we first
conducted perplexity experiments where
we measured perplexity of a language
model the definition of a perplexities
over here is basically related to the
cross entropy of the test data using the
your model and we use the upenn treebank
as our test as our copra here and there
are about 1,000,000 words and we use
ninety percent for training and ten
percent for held out in order to prune
the trees and so the baseline here first
is the connection I'd trigram using
interplay Deaconess Knights moving and
if we don't perform any randomization in
the distance reconstruction we have a
decision tree language model and if we
in this experiment we used to actually
100 random decision trees and now we
have a random forest run trigram this
interesting to see actually on how that
data and tested the decision tree
language model improved a little bit
only on how our data but instead it
actually hurt the performance a lot on
the tested and is that the random forest
trigram improved over ten percent on the
test data and of course we use the held
a lead from the trees and they helped
about twenty percent and whoops is
interesting to see as the number of
trees in the in the rain forest grows
how well the model performs and here i
have the plot of the random forest
trigram on the test data and held out
data as the function of number of these
entries in the random forest and the
middle line dotted line is actually the
baseline on
test data and the land above is the
baseline connection I model on the
Haldol data it's interesting you see
that we actually closing the gap between
the how that data and test it well the
decision trees are random and
occasionally you can have a bad decision
tree and will actually hurt the
performance a little bit but overall you
can see the improvements in with less
than ten trees yes good question is why
is the baseline perplexity would held
out worse than for the test it's just
because of the selection of the house
and the test data for that particular
selection is worse than the tested
the hell don't think I was not used for
estimating the place and I'm all the
name
it is used in my implementation of
connection I smoothing it's used to
estimate a discount constant
that's as it is fair because right
my discount constants that you have I
use simply one so I do not use three
different constants that they use one
also for the echinacea my baseline or
did you use three constants there I use
one also there and also I use one in the
decision tree yet in fact it's the same
one I did not optimize the discount
constant for this engine
and forth what's that guy's what was the
constant oh it's a four different order
it's slightly different for the Union
Graham order it's around point three
something like point three and four the
trigram is closed Oh point nine so
basically the for the trigram you trust
them less than the Union grams
right so now we want to have some
analysis why this is happening and we
analyze this by the term seen event in a
connection I diagram a senior band is
basically some anger and that happened
in a 10 in the training data and for the
decision tree is slightly different I
will see our state's it's a scene event
if it happened with any of the histories
in the equivalence class I will see
that's the scene event ok now I'm going
to analyze the test data event again
this is not by type by token by the
number of times they are considered
seeing in the 100 decision trees in this
case and I got this bar card here on the
x-axis again it's a number of times in
decision tree the first one is 0 which
means none in this category none of the
test data event can be mapped into the
sorry can be seen in any of the 100 e
symmetries it's the same time is 0 and
then I have different categories one to
nine and 10 to 19 and so on until a 10 I
have a hundred which means that the
tested events in that category are seen
in any of the 100's entries and it can
happen only for the scene events for the
connection diagram if if our Ingram is
seeing the training data and for sure it
will be mapped it to one of the leaves
and it will be seen there and that's why
we also have 100 that's interesting to
see as the number of times that the
events are seen in the distance in the
100 e centuries as the number of times
grows the relative improvement from the
random forest trigram
to the national program increases and
the that means the more times you use
you see that event in the decision trees
the more improvement you can get and I
cannot didn't show here in this plot but
basically if you break the bar even
further so it's basically after three
times you have seen that event in the
giantess entries you start to see
improvements small improvements and
overall the model run forest model
focuses on the events that cannot be
seen that connection I model and make a
difference there and for the the events
that are seen in both cases meaning in
the class and I try a try our model and
also a hundred times here in these
entries is almost the same you don't
lose their but you gain in other cases
in the 100 eccentric number of trees
that writing well but how does it relate
to the number of times it's seen in the
in the kinase and I trigrams it's only
the last part of the 100 that's the
trigram events that are seen in the
financial and from 0 to 99 those are the
events that you cannot see in in the
connection I driver so all 0 to 99 those
of the cases where you saw them that
number of times in the decision trees
and 10 times in case and I right and
then the the last bar is you saw it a
hundred times in the decision tree
exactly 100 or more than 100 exactly i
have only 100 you centuries so it's a
most 100 and then how many times do you
see it in the place
zero because the triangle event just
simply did not happen if all four events
that are not seen for compensating
trigram you're not comparing tried
things that you actually saw in the hit
the track in the regular trigram mortal
read the the events that i actually saw
in the trigram case last night case is
the last bar right so that's what all
the events that can have zero I have
nonzero accounts okay and then for the
last bar it's like all the events there
it's basically for forty five percent of
the test data I don't understand why the
zero when you don't see it in your trees
you should be backing off to the vibe
I'm yes it's moving right and in nests
and I should be doing the same thing
well the there's a interpolation wait so
that just do two different in a bit
no actually when I say this is not seen
I didn't mean the history is not seen
and in the entire abandoned us the
history could be seen in that case for
class 9 smoothing under the centuries
moving you have a different replacement
wait right exactly so since it's a
pretty good for trigram we want to move
on to high order in grants and for yes
sure this is the book these graphs are
the perplexity reduction for those
number of times in but now you have like
what fraction of events so like you have
to come right right it's about eight
percent for the zero category and then
the more times you see in the in the
Syrian trees the last the percentage is
but that's why I put them into
categories like 129 + + 10 to 19 and so
on so so the number of completely unseen
ones in his events in this entry is
eight percent right and in your baseline
you had that number earlier it's about
fifty four percent
so if we move on to higher order in
grants and for four or five six and the
class and I roll we see improvements
from trigram to program and small from
four to five and almost nothing from
five to six and we have almost the same
trend here for the random forests and so
this is the good news is we can still
get improvements from high or engrams
but the bad thing is we don't gain as
much as the trigram for for example 5
gram at six grand and we would like to
see why this is the case and actually if
you look at the smoothing on top is the
distinctive moving we used before and we
back up to the finish line intracom case
the diagram and in the sixth gram case
we will be backing off to the connection
i five grand and we know the random
forest five grams should be better than
the conventional 5 gram so why don't we
back up to the random forest lower order
probabilities and that's why we have
this embedded approach where we use a
better smoothing to embed into our
decision trees moving so for each
decision tree we have a lower order
random forest model for backing off and
the the rest of the tools moving
approaches are exactly the same
in that case we again have the same
table here with one more row the
embedded random forest approach but we
see actually we got much more gainful
for gram and a small amount for five
grand from the random force to the
embedded run forest yes
so the inverted random forest now though
it doesn't use any sort of nasonex it
doesn't use Kinect nice smoothing
explicitly but the way I counted the
event is still the same as the class 9
so I don't use kinetra as the smoothing
but I use the same way to to count the
events basically for in a trigram case
for any by Graham is not the background
the number of times that vibram occurred
in the training data is the number of
different trigrams that by Graham
occurred in so you're saying that your
borrowing some from from the days and I
wing doing things but when you're
backing off your backing off to your own
the lower right
the number of for each decision tree you
have to create a separate random forest
for the lower order yes total number of
decision trees is now much higher well
it's the same I mean I create a hundred
for example hundred centuries for the
background and then for trigram I don't
recreate any of the background is in
trees i just use those 100 for smoothing
so I still have hunger for each other
okay yeah I have a red language my line
papers for a while I mean is this result
exciting or so so er like Nobel Prize or
mr. I think going more than ten percent
of reduction from the interpolated
connection I'd model is exciting news
people have been trying to beat in
printer played Canasta I for 78 years
and not many models can beat interpreted
connection I using the same statistics
classroom model can help in some cases
and I will show in a couple of slides
later yes three went to see crime are
the perfect information so Leo is it
normal it is it is normal I actually
computed the conditional mutual
information of for example in the in the
trigram case so sorry in the foreground
case it's like adding one more word to
the trigram you can compute the mutual
information of the predicted word and
the word you are going to add given the
word you will already had right and
that's the indication how much you are
expecting from adding that one more word
in in fact four five and six gram that's
very small the reason is for this
training data we have only 1 million
words again 55 grand almost all the five
grams have come one
and you don't really gain by adding the
sixth work yep the question is what way
from that observation i could imagine to
take away one is don't bother with
longer and grams and the other one is i
get a decent sized training yeah well i
will show you a decent size of that
later okay so remember i have I had this
slide before should saying improvements
in smoothing should help other means of
this vastness like I try the class ring
so there are three simple clattering
approaches you can find the details in
Goodman's 2001 publication and the first
one is called a predict here I highlight
the the component of that model in which
i used apply the random forest approach
for the other component I still used
Dresner so and then for the three it's
actually interesting if I use 64 classes
for the first class ring model I can get
a capacity of about 140 and this is a
small improvement from the canals night
model but if I apply the run forest to
only the second part then I can still
get additional improvements and for the
other two classroom models we don't see
improvements in even comparing to the
connection I trigram I actually got
worse and still if we apply the running
for its approach we can get much better
gain there yeah so sorry I don't
remember your exact without those
numbers for Canadian I index indicates
are worse than
the baseline is that what you're sorry
the baseline is 140 50 so I got pretty
good improvements you have any
explanation for I I did it you did it I
read I ready or 2000 i see SLP paper in
which you actually tried a data size of
one meaning words yeah in which you do
not get improvement for that two pieces
it's only later on in the 2001
publication you did get improvements for
the 1,000,000 word coppers and for some
copper smaller than that you still don't
gain by using the index and index
predict and then also are obviously are
not the best for the clustering
techniques i report is there some reason
you didn't try some of that the better
ones no i didn't try the better ones
for the just because this those two
those three cases are simple for me to
try out and also it depends on the
number of clusters you get for each
position and that I think matters a lot
and what we got here is only one try we
do not try other numbers and the point
here is to show applying the random
forest approach to the components of a
classroom model can still get additional
input
so why is it that you applied there and
importance to some of them but not go do
this yeah the problem is this if you
look at the first component of the
predict model it's the word given the
two pair of words and the class in that
in which case you will have because we
always spoke Urdu hard clustering so a
word can belong to only one class then
for each class you have a different
vocabulary and you have a different
amount of training it sometimes there is
only one word in one class so you
basically don't get anything if the
probability will simply be one for that
word and zero for others so I not get
into that because there are too many
class classes do you get is that it
won't actually help you what if you go
right it may not help I enjoy
yeah for the second model if you see the
second component you get the same amount
of training later as the trigram case
okay then I try this with the structure
language model in a strike language
model we try to assign a joint
probability distribution to parse and
the word the probability distribution is
in this product form we have three
components for predictor tagger and
parser and the difficulty here of of
applying the random forest approaches
you have three components then you have
you need three running forest
probabilities and it is not easy to fit
100 decision trees for each model into
the memory so that you can have an
online computation and that's why we
took a different approach where we use a
different decision tree triple for the
three models so each time the three
decision trees are different and we
compute the probabilities and then get a
word probably word by word probability
finally we take the average of that we
see this as an approximation of what we
want to do and still on the comparing to
the connection at baseline in which we
got 138 it's already better than the
baseline trigram and we we can improve
that by more than ten percent and reduce
that to about 123 so to sum up the
perplexity results we have this table
where we try different models and we see
the Ingram and struck length model are
the cases probably worth trying out for
the speech recognition experiments
simply because the relative improvements
in the two cases are more than ten
percent and much better than the
baseline
so for speech recognition we tried two
different copper the first one is the
Wall Street Journal and we perform
ambassador scoring and we used either 20
or 40 million words of training data and
we used the DARPA 93 hub one test data
for evaluating the performance this is a
fairly small test set it has about three
three three thousand five hundred words
so the baseline where it is about 13.7
which uses cash back off for smoothing
and over 40 million words in training
data and the Oracle error rate which is
the best possible you can get on this
invested is about six percent so if we
apply a random forest in the same way as
before for the trigram on 20 million or
40 million words we got significant
improvement in word array and notice
here the using 20 million words we
already got better result than using 40
million words with the Kenaz nice movie
and we used this for the strategy
language model but since it's a fairly
large amount of data probably that not
that large only 20 million words we
couldn't fit the the other decision
trees to all three different models
instead we used the decent random
distinctions for only the predictor
model and still we got about one percent
gain in the water it and this is again a
very small test set and a very fairly
amount of data but not a huge amount of
data right and then last year in the
speech relation evaluation IBN used
about more than 800 million words in
your language models it's a
conversational telephony speech
system for rich transcription in which
rADM scored number one in the evaluation
there there are different Cobra the
Fisher data is about 22 million words
and there's web data collected by
University of Washington 525 million
words I would say this is a fair amount
of data and the lattice language model
used for Graham with Interpol it ignites
and I smoothing and pruned to have only
3.2 million unique immigrants that's
only for the implementation of IBM so
the test set is here is what we call a
dev 0 Forrester sadly used to test their
systems it has about thirty seven
thousand words in a test so we used the
110 run dis entries for embedded random
forests for Graham and the reason to
choose 110 is not a significant because
this is a larger amount of data
sometimes the tree construction will
crash so I always run more try to
construct more trees than 100 so in this
case 110 really were constructed so I
use all of them and we sample the data
without replacement just for efficiency
and in a baseline model I mentioned
before it has 3.2 million unique engrams
the baseline result was 14.4 and if you
risk or that using a feature for Graham
connection I model and you get about
point three percent again which is 14.1
no here and if you interpolate the
feature model and the web model from 525
million words you you get additional
point four percent and if I construct
random forest on the 20 million words of
Fisher data I can reduce the word every
2 13.5 which is already better than the
last night model with more than 500
million words and if I again use the
random forest model for also the web
data for which I also sampled without
replacement to manageable size and use a
different sample for each different
energy I can get the back the point four
percent gain from adding this data and
both improvements are statistically
significant we also have perplexity
numbers but I don't have plenty numbers
but was the relative improvement in
perplexity
yeah so with you
did you say that the IBM baseline was a
14.4 yeah that's when they use a 3.2
million in Graham County small
they always focus oh you were saying
that this because they prune their
language model but writers they use
Fisher data and they use the web data
just as you did no they actually used
all other data from switchboard
broadcast news and so on in which they
reduce the word arrow to 13 point the
form to use 800 million words instead of
so this is not on the state of the art
based on their Thursday the net result
is 13.4 yes the absolute path resulting
again for this has said is starting
platform and you could not run on the
baseline it's interpolation of seven
different lengths models from which we
found the feature and web data are the
most important component that's why we
chose to run this and even if I took the
other models as is using a interpolated
connection on moda smoothing and still
using the same interpolation weight and
interpolate with my random first model
so i can still get 13.1
so so
I'm so basically so by saying that if
you think they still steady state of
their ad lattices which are 13.4 14.4
thus the lattice is beginning mmm then
if the baby we can take this offline oh
oh basically the improvement form using
this approach can be applied to all the
components right I tried two components
and this is already better than the
absolute bassline they use everything
like 800 million words
so is the point day if you wanted to do
a fat compassion but that you would have
to build on m4s on five more poker face
the result is dlc GOP foster general
know there's a figure on the Fisher
conversation personal yes please okay so
you took the lettuce that have been
generated right which they were put in
your article right
so now we can see the actually there are
para practical limitations in this
approach is basically in the memory
usage and the decision tree construction
uses much more memory than the
interpolator national and it's not easy
therefore to realize the performance
gain when the Trinity that is really
large much larger than 500 million words
let's say so we always used more than
100 trees and the final model becomes
too large to fit into the memory
therefore we have to run the risk or in
parallel and that incurs extra
computational cost it depends on the
number of anger indistinct engrams in
your training data so basically it's a
less than half of the unique and grams
in the connection for example if Oh
Canada has a million unique Ingram's
sorry histories then the decision tree
will have less than half of that
on average if you compute the average
number of histories in a node it will be
like two to three
so therefore we think some effective
language model compression or pruning is
still an open question for this approach
in conclusion I have constructed a
random forest modern approach for
language models and is the more general
representation for language models
because it is a superset of distinction
language models and again a superset of
Engram language models and the
randomization in this approach actually
does randomized history clustering and
in which we again a very good
generalization power is better than
Ingram go the in coverage and also is
less biased toward the training data and
we extended Brahmins random forest idea
to in this work to deal with the data
person's problem and the random forests
actually have the the power of focusing
on some words in some decision trees and
some other words in some others so
that's why the collaborative
contribution of the trees achieved for
significant improvements and then we
show the improvements in perpetually and
both productive and where it over the
interpolated canesten I for different
models including ngrams class-based the
structure language model and we achieved
a significant improvements in the best
performing large vocab recomposition or
telephone a speech system for 2004
thank you the official results as a
function of n distinct when I don't have
that I don't have a regular IBM off with
our ppl in the in there RT bookshop they
actually show that you should hire other
and Graham are doing better and a little
other food is so easy to use the forum
IBM i don't think at the end is that
mainly because it is it could be
slightly better if use five gram because
of the large amount of data available
but i don't know how much better always
that's probably the same thing will
happen in your cage whereas your
propensity result don't really show much
for the 1 million words yeah yeah it's
the head will be able to data right this
is there something bigger can you point
out what's special about decision trees
paid you want to choose those to do the
history clustering could you imagine
using another classifier that doesn't
have the drawbacks of decision trees to
do his
or is there something about decision
trees that makes them stand apart the
reason we use the decision tree is the
automatic automatic question
construction question selection in the
tree construction that's the only reason
we use to this entry
if if there are other classifiers which
can do the same thing and with which
doesn't have the drawback of these
injuries I think it would be interesting
to try that out yes but you haven't
asking fewer classes in Korea ah so a
long time ago at IBM I think I think the
group included included Fred they used
decision trees for language along with a
big with clusters you know you know the
work I'm talking about right you can you
compare your work to it to their work
well be the used 20 words in the history
and what we found was the decision
itself is not better than they used
interplay in a deleted interpolation at
that time for smoothing in a trigram and
the decision tree with 20 words in the
history was not better than the trigram
and he's only when the interpolated with
the trigram because I'm I think about
the seven percent improvement
I will say if they use in chocolate
ganache an eye for that case I don't
know if they can get same amount of
improvement in my approach another thing
is I tried to interpolate the connection
I model with the random forest motor I
present here and there's no further
improvements by doing that so it's
basically the rain forest at one end and
the connection at the other end is the
straight line so I have two questions so
first question is in the switchboard
experiments you all of a sudden needed
to do sampling of the training data and
it's unclear you did not experiment with
sampling interacting with your decision
tree random forest building procedure on
new pantry by important are you think
Rebecca actor did oh you did yes I do
not show here actually so I would think
that somehow the sampling the way your
sample may matter like anyone we change
around here that's from happen in fact
if I just sample the data if I don't
perform other randomization in the
decidua century comes fracture I can
still get a running for small hey that
one was not as good as if I do
randomization in both cases and then the
final result was it's almost the same as
if I don't sample the data
yet another dimension along which you
randomize the decision to write crime
site and that dimension is not going to
change the result much in the same which
I have this IR I don't understand very
well what the
model size is like storage wise how many
parameters know I need to store relative
to an end run and the reason I'm asking
this is because that's important
I always have the option of growing the
Ngram beaker yes I can poor training
data just as this IBM guys are doing and
I can grow it deeper like use higher
order indian graph and those are you
know sort of legitimate ways of the
Engram can to compete with your approach
I'm looking right so you have many
comments of that so far I did not look
into the Cronin approach for my random
forest model so I'm using a very
straightforward storage I mean way of
starring the the decision trees and
accounts so it's basically one different
tree it's almost the same as one
international platform in storage
pacifica 100 times so if you grow the
the
the size of the model 100 times I think
from what IBM did you gain from 14.12
13.4 by growing model from funny million
words to about 800 million words so 40
times
remember the model girls 40 times oh
that's true so
yeah alright so that's the only thing i
can say i don't get a significant troop
rice chicken i don't agree with you
because IBM used more data and squeeze
the last drop they could for the
evaluation and reporters 13.4 if your
subset of that data and has end up
so to argue that you could use more data
and grow the model where apparently not
because it right there so another thing
I would like to say is I can use my
model to the in demand data for example
this case feed the fish a day and
interpolate with whatever the model they
want to build using more data in which I
probably cannot handle and then I can
still get a significant improvement on
top of that to me seems like this
strengthened
the last straw from
the amount of data that you know that
it's very relevant to your task okay and
that's where you gain right over some
modern approach they can they can throw
more data at it but the data is not that
relevant it doesn't help them all that
much if you just focus on the training
data force which were Fisher or whatever
it is you can squeeze the last drop out
of it and that's helping right or is
that you know throwing what is it so i
think it's an interesting thing job will
relating to classes that besides the
split the tree y'all talking about
identity I don't think it's the best
basic terrible thing this is a it's a
very mechanical thing than you think
better but the thing is we also try the
inner structure on which model in which
it will be slightly different right you
don't you don't just ask about the word
identity also asked about the syntactic
label of Henderson and so on and we also
try to help to ask about the word
cluster identity in a word clustering
approach and that game for almost
exactly exactly the same performance as
where identity stone so before we
can figure out what's good to ask about
I think this approach is
straightforward but there is no resistor
or how to optimally constructor
questions not yet oh yeah that's a
pretty much open area this one so the
back of you always back up to the order
either an Engram mess and I although
order forest but within the tree you
think about just backing off of the tree
so you know using these but internal
nodes initially I tried that and I
didn't find that better than the
national coach will you back off using
like a knife I'll back off I know but
the problem there is there there are too
many levels in the tree and also the
criteria we use to evaluate the
questions is Trinity the likelihood it's
very often that along the path you see
similar behavior right if you back off
maybe very to the very beginning of the
tree you may catch something Graham
there and then because of the back of
weight the probability becomes much
smaller and you don't really get
because it seems like you can probably
get a little bit more by doing the
equations clustering of the histories
and and the predictor work together but
it seems like you can is that what
you're saying well if you like for
example neural network model basically
seems to do everything right you just
throw everything at it and it fills a
cluster but as you're basically building
a cluster using the history part only
and then you are using some other
methods to class right so it's kind of
interesting that you did not get any
further improvement by trying to unify
the two together I don't think that's
the best way to unify the two because oh
no that's true I learn you to be
interacting with the Charter exactly and
I haven't figured out how this
interaction should be done well whatever
and clustering questions also I thought
that's only for the clustering of the
history words oh ok also you did not you
have not yet tried to combine the two
now the question I have is do you see
the similar kind of trend where you're
with the number of fries it saturates
very quickly even on a larger purpose
for the IBM system since I did not test
the black city so I don't have that but
for The Wall Street Journal that
reporting any words I eat fine I did
find the warrior a trained in a number
of these entries it's very interesting
that the best you can do is not by
having 100 G's is by having about 10 or
20 because sometimes you're lucky you
get a hundred area 10 good trees and and
some later part you get 10 batteries and
that kind of compensate each other and
then basically the power is the
convergence the more you have the better
you get the did you end up using counter
pine trees or 100 in the results you
presented 100 this kind of a media this
is a top freeze is huge and the fact
that you can get saturated quickly maybe
it has something to do with the fact
that you're actually skewing your
selection criteria are heavily towards a
certain good direction yeah even even
for good treats the space is still
enormous because I'll do this
randomization at each node and why
but interest is not saturated yet even
with hundred you cannot simply say it's
saturated right it's just doesn't know
it is about that it oh yeah there it is
noticeable that I hadn't taken number to
stop I would break time that means you
can probably squeeze out a very small
amount from adding more treats but the
significant if a'kin count around this
from the beginning sorry either that or
it's because you know your distribution
is not your juice queuing your selection
criteria so heavily but that that by
increasing the number you are not
getting enough diversity is that
possible that's that's possible but
that's not very likely because at each
node the problem with this approach also
we is with each node I don't know how
many possibilities they are because I
don't know how many local Optima they
are so I can only try a initial random
initialization and let it go so it in
your question you think maybe in some
cases we have very similar treats
basically because the Miller criteria
they will not be exploring the space
police or sheriff ah yes everywhere
might look different by share the same
bias yeah that's possible yes okay
one last question and that's
basically the actual ask you later
okay thank you